this show is brought to you by blue
apron
go to blueapron.com and check out the
week's menus and get your first two
meals for free with free shipping that's
right your first two meals are free and
you get free shipping when you go to
blueapron.com joey you'll love how it
feels and tastes to create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue ribbon so
don't wait that's blueapron.com
joey blueapron.com joey
show is also brought to you by club w
right now club w is offering our
listeners twenty dollars off of your
first order when you go to clubw.com
joey and buy all of their great wines
and it gets even better i know you hate
paying for shipping so club w will
actually pay for your shipping on orders
of four bottles or more so go to
clubw.com joey right now to get twenty
dollars off of your first order with
free shipping if you buy four bottles or
more and go to onyt.com and use codeword
church to save ten percent on all of the
great optimization products like alpha
brand new mood shroom tech immune and
shroom tech support
oh [ __ ]
lee's about to see the devil
it's wednesday june 8th
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive
lee syed brodie stevens
uncle joey
becky's in studio
are you kidding me or what
the church of what's happening now
[ __ ]
a little old def leopard for you from 80
[ __ ] three
people were smoking bazookas to this
[ __ ] song right here i was one of
them
yeah old school leopard
i still remember waking up
and the drummer got in the car accident
lost his arm i still haven't waking up
to mtv that was the story on mtv like
breaking story on mtv
they lost his arm yeah disarmed i think
it was january 1st 1984
or 85. in a car wreck and a car wreck in
[ __ ] europe or somewhere yeah england
but he came back
sure he came back he's still out there
isn't he one-armed drummer the one-armed
drummer [ __ ] giving it hell what's
happening brody stevens enjoy it great
to be here joey i'm excited i'm thankful
uh it's in the neighborhood it's nice
summer's coming out i'm exercising
um i'm happy i'm very happy i'm happy
that you're [ __ ] happy you understand
me when i saw you a few weeks ago i
could see the happiness glowing out of
your [ __ ] boys well i was with it was
witch hazel it was witch hazel lisa
what's going on with you i'm feeling
great having a good day getting some
kettlebells this morning i did 200
swings this morning i couldn't believe
it it was crazy we did 20
swing no we did 10 swings for 20 minutes
and that was on the minute on the minute
with 24 kilograms which isn't super
heavy but
24 kilograms is 48 pounds about 50. it's
a little bit more that's not bad lee oh
my god you're [ __ ] doing it at least
making it happen wow that's a lot it's
four matters correct oh it's all about
weight well that's what they say they
always say like uh the guy says like
because i don't know i get competitive
with myself so every i like not every
class but i try to go up and wait
but
he's the the guy i go with is really big
on
he wants it to be perfect for him
because it if you're doing 3000 with
shitty form it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
so you try to get
a number of swings in the it's a numbers
game well no it's a class so he tells us
like we don't always do swings
um
but we
so like for today we did uh five presses
on each side and five squats and we did
that four times
and then from there we went to swing so
every class is different
so it's
sometimes it's suing for 30 seconds
and just see what you get usually it's
every minute on the minute for like 10
or 15 swings
yeah these kettlebell workouts you do
them they get your heart rate up this is
a high intensity training
and i've been cried at them today also
but i just want to get carried away you
start feeling
good and you overdo it that's been my
problem but that's that's why keeping my
weights down to like just the 25s you've
been with kettlebells for a few years
now you've been a proponent of the
kettlebell
well they were defunded they were fun to
do it was good for uh once i can get
that you know you can get a great cardio
workout and flexibility
so it was all for in
in lining you up you know kettlebells
once once you do them you like them now
you've always been a proponent of the
workout when i first met you in seattle
were you working on that no okay i
played baseball so i was in college i
played baseball we worked out but i was
also playing baseball then i went to
seattle and i really wasn't doing much
exercise i don't know and your mood
changes when you exercise when you're
exercising oh yeah of course those
endorphins uh sweat
confidence
you know getting a good stretch in
you know so i mean it definitely affects
me but you know sometimes i'm taking too
much caffeine that's my problem too you
know it's like yeah coffee dude
two or three cups a day
but i'll take a five hour energy i need
a kick sometimes to get
me going to get a workout in
but it's
i'm not saying i have an addictive
addictive personality but uh that could
be my problem but i do like working out
i like kettlebells because i feel like
it's just you do them outside in the sun
could do i would i back in the day i
would my old apartment i'd go out in the
afternoon i used to love going to north
hollywood park i have two kettlebells in
the trunk and i'll go off i got an
eight-pound ball
and i'll stretch i'll do some swings
i'll do some cleans i'll do some sit-ups
and then i'll do a lap or two like just
walk around yeah exactly you [ __ ] get
sore the next day jack you're like damn
i didn't even do nothing it's uh
it's an underrated park by the way north
hollywood and there's a little bit of an
edge to it i like it i'll go there i'll
take a lap there
and the kettlebells yeah you just drag
them throw them around my thing is i'm
playing baseball also i like throwing
the baseball so i sometimes
i can't overdo it when playing baseball
because then my arm can be tender my
elbow that's why form is so important on
the kettlebells but
because i've been building up slowly and
my pitching mechanics are better i've
been able to avoid inner injuries i'm
wiser now i'm wiser
and i'm able to avoid injury and i'm
actually doing rehab exercises to to
strengthen the tendons around my uh
my elbow how'd you sleep
do you sleep i've been sleeping great i
do urinate five nights a time five
nights at a time five times a night all
right here's the clinker yeah you ready
sure a doctor bumped into me and said
that's what's killing you because that's
what was killing me
what kills me is you gotta [ __ ] pee
at night and the older you get yeah
jesus christ
jesus christ so for about a year
my big thing was to stop at the comedy
store and beat the clock and get a
starbucks venti a [ __ ] flat white at
midnight you know i could do a [ __ ]
venti admittedly okay yeah for the 30
years of blow i broke that [ __ ] yeah
no caffeine don't work on papa gotcha i
could drink a whole thing at starbucks
and be in bed 30 minutes later i could
do that yeah so mine over but what that
does to you is
because coffee is a diuretic whatever
the [ __ ] is a diuretic so you drink
coffee at night and you're off and
running you're having nightmares about
people peeing on you yeah that's how
many times you got to [ __ ] be you
have nightmares about people peeing on
you yeah so i had to cut that out but
here's the secret
they say over a certain age now they
really confuse you they say they want
you to take an aspirin at night before
you go to bed with
a glass of water
and i'm sitting there going i took a
glass of water and then i'm back to
square zero
the sleep apnea everything goes out the
window because what happens with me my
sleep pattern is basic
let's say i go to bed at 11 o'clock i'll
sleep solid till [ __ ] four
that's six hours that's five hours right
yeah five hours okay at the five or six
hour mark i gotta pee
so as i'm walking to the bathroom i'm
praying to god that this isn't a long
[ __ ] pee
if it's longer than a minute and a half
i'm done
because you pee for a minute and a half
whatever the [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] you
know you're standing there you're half
asleep i don't know if it's a minute an
hour i don't know what you're drinking
out of my fat man body so when i walk
back
what happens to me is if i have a
thought lingering that's been bothering
me
and i let that thought get into my mind
on the walk back to the bed and while i
put my sleep apnea mask on
it grows in my head like a [ __ ] weed
and i got up really so i got sick and
tired of that challenging my sleep so i
was talking to this dude and he goes
what you do is when you're a comedian
you work on your legs
he goes you do five spots in new york
when you get home believe it or not your
legs have fluid in them
so when you go home at night the first
thing i do when i go home is i wash my
hands you're shaking all these [ __ ]
monkeys hands right you wash your hands
and i
get water
like a little bit like eight ounces and
i sit and learn when i watch tv and
unwind i make notes about my set i call
lee
i return a call and i know somebody was
up late but the whole time my legs are
elevated okay
and you see that in that half hour
period that you're cooling down you'll
start peeing
because your legs are elevated so all
that will uh that's what happens when
you go to bed at night your legs are
elevated so now all that uh
water that you had in your legs that
your fluid that you were retaining you
got to pee it out
i think uh some of it's also medication
you're on a certain amount i i noticed
when i was well i got blood pressure
medications yeah that's going to give it
to your [ __ ] out all too i'm just used
to going to i'm just conditioned now to
getting up and going to pee four nights
four times a night and i go right back
to sleep by the way i'm able to i'm
gonna cut three of those pete if i could
cut three of those [ __ ] peas out give
me a jug i used to pee in the jug done
done what you're gonna do is you're
gonna
put your feet up go to [ __ ] on the
way home go to target and go to the
middle of target and look up they got
those little feet feet posted squatty
potty it's 14.99
and you can take it off and hide your
notebook in there wet your pen your pot
pipe your lighter your weed and put the
cover over it and sit over it like a
[ __ ] zombo so that's what i do my
shit's all hidden in there i got a
notebook to write jokes in the living
room because i can't go in the bedroom
because my wife is sleeping right so i
put my feet up and i put a pillow up to
elevate it over my [ __ ] heart and all
that moisture in your [ __ ] feet and
your legs goes to your nut sack
and right before you go to bed you drain
your [ __ ] vein they're beds for that
don't they they're like the incline beds
incline beds but that means you're gonna
have to get up in the middle of the
[ __ ] night brody stevens i'm trying
to save you that's what i did the jug
for i was and that's not healthy i used
to pee in a jug and started that in new
york [ __ ] jug that's disgusting
that's like me [ __ ] not the [ __ ]
window i used to do that well peeing a
jug no not in drugs in like bottles or
cans if i didn't want to get up hell
yeah that's disgusting
i was in a weekly ho i was sharing a
hotel uh
hotel a weekly hotel with lahai was
there and it was in new york city that's
where i got in the habit of peeing into
a jug
because you had to share
you had to walk down the hallway to use
the restroom and go you know what i'm
going to avoid the middle man give me
that jug boom started feeling
one of those hotels where the whole
floor uses the one bathroom well i did
that for the 60 dollars a week one of
those yeah
when i first moved to new york city yeah
i stayed there for about i don't know a
couple months while i was looking for an
apartment and i ended up finding a
studio out in uh brooklyn
out off the l train in williamsburg
brooklyn so you told me to go to new
york you were the one who said brody go
to new york you told me that in seattle
they'll get you go to surf reality go
downtown just
be you that alternative stuff or
whatever you want to call it it's crazy
i was you just gave me a memory how when
i lived in san francisco i was a
full-time burglar
so i would live in one of those hotels
where people
took the shower in the hallway so i
would rob them when they were in the
shower
i'd wait for them to go in the shower
and then the word got out that people
get robbed when they're in the shower
people were taking the belongings in the
shower with them it was like a [ __ ]
luggage thing they were taking them but
i would lock it
aha what your apartment you got it yeah
it didn't matter i had a security key oh
you did yes what the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with some novice i'm
gonna go in there you open the door
that's a no-brainer that's stupid oh you
had a key i had keys
plural oh man i knew ways what i would
do i would practice on my own door
because all the doors were the same so i
would just practice on my own door
so when i lived in in uh how do you
practice if you have a key
because you you practice you make
believe you're [ __ ] locked out you
never do that make believe you're locked
up no i i don't ever that's how you find
that if your house is burglar proof
oh mine is i've broken into my i've
broken into my apartment here twice
because i locked my keys inside and i
have that window i still have to get
that bar from my window but oh i've
broken into my apartment twice and been
like and like no one says anything on
the second floor third floor yeah you've
climbed to the [ __ ] things like
spiderman no because there's a window
onto the belt onto the walkway so i just
pop it open and let it slide through but
no i don't do it just to see i mean i
guess that would be a good idea okay so
let's say you live in an apartment
complex when i lived in snowmass in 83 i
was in an apartment complex okay and
that complex is a to k
so that's a b c d e f g h i j k 11
[ __ ] buildings
so all the doors were the same
you follow me so i would practice on my
door how long it would take me to break
into a place like on the timer what the
[ __ ] do you think you're dealing with
some [ __ ] [ __ ] here when i went
deep i went deep
so let's say your door has the railing
there with the [ __ ] thing i practice
how to get a screwdriver
pop it in pop pop out that thing so i
could sip my [ __ ] i used to get saws
those saw blades
and i would pick your [ __ ] door and
what would happen when your neighbors
would walk by that nobody would walk by
i was shoveling snow
they thought i was down there shoveling
snow were you doing this for fun was
this a hobby was this when i was
burglarizing yes i was doing drug
dealers i would know who the drug
dealers were even in snow masks they
would go skiing
right and as soon as they got on that
hill they can't take that pound of coke
with them
so you were going after the drug all the
drug dealers in that neighborhood it's
like a pied piper thing like a pie piper
but for myself i didn't give another
nobody so you were robin from like
regular people yeah
oh great well i lived in the hotel but
they were kind of tourists i would get
travellers checks and bring them down to
japan town and [ __ ] like that right yeah
of course tourists no problem but they
get insurance on travelers yeah don't
leave home without them i'll leave home
without them horrible i never felt
guilty about travelers so yeah drug heal
that's good that's good breaking in
there you get a rush over that right oh
my god the other night i was watching a
movie with ed norton and robert de niro
about stealing a [ __ ] wand it's one
of the worst movies of all time in
montreal with angela bassett marlon
brando i got caught up because it's jim
norton what's his name jim edna ed
norton
my heart was [ __ ] beating like i was
robbing the place
and i loved it my dick was i loved that
[ __ ] i love that that's a complete
different rush tonight the score like
[ __ ] yeah the score like fighting is one
thing
he's [ __ ] there's one thing
but doing something of a criminal
activity stealing for a long time just
anything over trespassing anything
anything i loved it
my heart would beat a certain way my
ears would ring a certain way
you ever try to sneak into places like
events just say let me see if i can try
and sneak in even though you can get a
ticket or you have a ticket when i was a
kid i snuck into the garden for
everything because what you do is you go
to one
game a season so you go to a nic game
right you pay the 15 and you get the
ticket stub yeah so then you take 20 and
you put on that stuff next time you go
to the garden and you stub your way in
that's what that was called in those
days so you stub your way in and
basically you don't have a seat
so now you got to go get a seat they let
you in you're in wait so for 20 bucks
yeah for 10 bucks you know i went to see
ted nugent and acds i put a 10 under a
ticket they let me in yeah i went to see
the sixes against the next on christmas
day one time i put a 10 under a ticket
gotcha and they let me we used to sneak
into the forum with the laker games
really yeah we would go in there you can
go into the forum we did it this way so
if you we would go in and if you left
the the
okay this is what we did basically to
make it a long story short if you left
to go smoke or whatever they would like
you put an x on your ticket with a paper
like a x so we took the ticket and we
slipped it through the door and our
friend had the ticket stub so now he had
the ticket we were in is this the door
to inside the outside he had the ticket
stub he wrote the x on it went to where
boomi walked in you see what i'm saying
right it was like real easy so we snuck
into like laker clipper game laker
celtic games back in the day if they
ever catch you no yeah no would you sit
uh this was uh like standing room only i
know guys were moving around we had like
i was i don't believe me i want a seat
i'm not one of those guys who's
comfortable bouncing around the lakers
played at the forum like the forum was
inglewood as scary back then like was it
when the lakers played in englewood was
worse guys um inglewood was all right
but no it was like known as what it is
now kind of like a little edgy but the
forum i'm sure was safe in the parking
lot but i used to go to like two or
three games a year like again when the
south celtics would come to town
saw the nuggets trailblazers but yeah we
would sneak in and then um also the l.a
king games my friend worked there so we
would get in and
there's you know a lot of that stuff
going on
but that was uh l.a back in the day that
was the spot to be the form was just uh
i was scared like the only place i ever
tried to sneak into were movies and i
still that's even scary no well no well
because i would i'd at least buy one
ticket it's not like i never really
wanted you buy one ticket you go to
three [ __ ] movies
yeah they don't even give a [ __ ] oh they
don't they know you're doing it
you know who gives a [ __ ] that pimple
face glasses [ __ ] that's 16. i
know that kid that wants to be a cop in
[ __ ] eight years i've seen him
he's the one that comes up to you and
tries to spray you with deodorant and
[ __ ] like i i'll zap you but they even
told them when they did do not use
physical altercation just let them this
guy's a [ __ ] idiot what about getting
a refill i i got i got busted one time
for getting a refill at a circle k in
tempe hey you know did the lady like
clamped down on me
what'd she say to you she said you can't
do that
i i had i or i had i got the soda i was
like a 32 ounce thirst buster it's tempe
it's hot i remember i'm drinking the
soda i'm like looking at the magazines
checking out the stuff now oh it's all
halfway through me go get some more and
she like hey you can't do that i
remember it did she call the cops no but
she like put she like came down on me
for it there's a
you remember these incidents in your
life when people came down on you for
stuff i remember at the circus one time
have you heard of circus vargas
no you've already like yeah circus
vargas is like a local circus
and they had it was over at like
hollywood and highland and this when i
was a kid and uh some ladies that i
snuck into the into the big top i
remember she grabbed my collar i
remember so whenever i think of circus
vargas it's still around i see it i have
flashbacks to that lady grabbing me
sneaking in and i wasn't sneaking in i'm
a good kid i got
i'm so upset now no but i remember i got
busted for uh
some lady thought i was uh shoplifting
some people like uh i've been accused of
a lot of stuff that i didn't do
i don't know why
i got busted for cheating in school were
you cheating yeah i was in fourth grade
there you go and i had the listen how
stupid i was i had the book
under my shirt
and my teacher knew it and he said stand
up and the book got caught under the
desk
i was like so there was that that was
terrible i got caught
doing uh
what is it not not like not shoplifting
masturbating oh no i haven't i haven't
that would be terrible have you guys
ever got a comment almost
almost i don't what i was gonna say i
got caught by an ex-girlfriend she
wanted to take a shower she came out i
was sniffing the panties
you know me i'm a soldier of death
it was like eight in the morning we were
snoring coke i was all coked up i just
sniffed the [ __ ] panties
she came out with a towel and she goes
you're not sniffing my panties i said
you bet your ass and i'm gonna come on
and do
[ __ ] that if you put these things back
on you're pregnant as a [ __ ]
what about shoes like little feet and
socks no you don't have a foot fetish no
really i like women's feet i won't suck
them or nothing like that but if a girl
says look uh here's here's panties or
a sock what do you want to hold panties
i'd probably take a sock do you i think
so somebody was telling me there's a
girl that gets money for sending you
grungy underwear there's a lot of girls
who do that yeah they send you socks
that are worn oh really after they go to
yoga sign me up what do you like about
feet brody
what happened in japan
just the the shape the shape of the toe
the the nail the uh the the bones gonna
put your boots on like i kind of like
when they have like when they're
lined up good and
i like when they're a little bony
and uh clean i like them clean
i mean i can get dirty though i can walk
you know i'm not a sex fiend with a foot
i like a woman's foot i think it's
beautiful
i think uh
when i see a fat chick with fat feet and
she has sandals on at the airport i want
to tell her husband stop you didn't
advise him before you left the [ __ ]
house he got some pair of balls i would
have said honey i love you to death
but you can't wear those [ __ ] sandals
it looks like a truck driver's feet
i see it all the [ __ ] time and the
guy should tell a woman can i talk to
you aside for a second i love feet i
love you to death you're a great cook i
love how you dance
but you can't wear those open toed
[ __ ] shoes every time you wear them i
have a [ __ ] heart attack i wake up in
the middle of night sometimes i think
i'm next to a guy named nick
look at the size of your [ __ ] feet
you're a godzilla but i love you that
that you're the mother of my children
but those feet gotta go we gotta do
something they're hoofs
what do you expect her response to be oh
thank you honey
i didn't know i didn't know women don't
know sometimes people just don't know i
got [ __ ] up feet right i got [ __ ] up
everything i know i have covered feet i
got [ __ ] up feet and i got the [ __ ]
nail toe people look at my foot in jiu
jitsu i get all embarrassed i had eczema
what what's worse did i put a band-aid
on my toe that looks like a [ __ ] half
a [ __ ]
so i might as well just go with the
fungi toes sticking out i don't give a
[ __ ] i trim it
you know i trim the face
it's fungus i've done everything i could
i went sebastian told me to spray the
thing listen i went up and got a
blowtorch do you know that's the server
you go on groupon and you go to sherman
oaks and some indian lady because it's
the only people that would do that blow
torch your toes hindus they're trying to
get back at somebody you go in the
morning
they get a [ __ ] hose with like a blue
hose with like coldest air ever and they
leave it on your toe until you don't
feel your toe then they blow torch your
[ __ ] toe right with like a torch and
you see the smoke and the fungi getting
burned oh
and you could smell it i was gonna say
what
my wife got it for me for christmas we
tried it
and then i go home and i [ __ ] pick
the nail up and spray sebastian said he
had to spray it on his toe for a year
every day so that's what i did for you
every day i sprayed it now the nail is
half of bots
like i've cut half of when i go to
hotels that's why i do my footwork i
don't work on my feet at my house
i do footwork in hotels i have my diet
dress on every corner joe why are you
doing this yourself what's a podiatrist
a foot doctor what do i want to go to
the foot doctor for he's going to say
he's going to help me he'll help you you
got to trim your feet and i got a sander
oh sander you got a foot sander you get
them online i got a foot sander cause my
feet crack and [ __ ] i got [ __ ] up skin
so what happens is i take my feet eczema
i soak it
i wait till the toenail comes out i cut
the fungus out i go deep i take the
brown stuff out oh
i definitely sniff it you know what mate
you gotta sniff that [ __ ] that's good
you have to do you have the least oh my
god do you like catalog it do you have
like a diary with like no no what you do
is you take the toenail and you get some
toe jam and you mix it all together like
a toe ball
and you sniff that fungi nail i think i
i i think i can help you
let me ask a question
are you do you take supplements you take
msm
do you know what
i
msm
do you take biocill i don't know why i
take i take supplements that
specifically focus on skin
connectivity
um
the the those tissues those uh
i don't i used to have skin ailments i
used to have uh bad nails skin jock itch
uh anal lesions so i got a jock itch
that i got a scar on my [ __ ] leg
from i'm just growing up in jersey and
scratching like i have a red scar it
looks like somebody blow torch
like not by my dick but away on my thigh
from growing up in that heat that heat
would kill me but these are these are
for collagen these are for nails i take
it my nails get stronger my eyebrows get
thicker i don't have again the the the
jock area the eczema that's also mental
but i used to have those problems i'm
telling you and i think if you tried
some msm msn i i thought you would you
know what msm is no um
yeah it's basic stuff msm it's in uh
condroitin it's in joint stuff but if
you take it it's strong i'm being
serious i'm dog for skin hair and nails
look at my nails i'll scratch the i'll
scratch somebody that's how strong they
are i i would say
when i heard that story about you having
that toenail thing i say give it a shot
i will biosil i got gnc tomorrow i'm
gonna go out of the way no don't do gnc
i don't think i don't think you want to
stop joey i think you like it what's the
toenail oh like just the process of
digging it out like is that why you do
it on the road so yeah it doesn't see it
so the maid sees like just cut [ __ ]
pieces of nail i take some of the jam
from underneath
oh i have to collect them i take one i
chew on it while i'm watching [ __ ]
the prison show
you're chew on the fungus [ __ ] yeah i
don't give a [ __ ]
i you know i've eaten hookers [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
do they get
are you serious yeah can you send me the
one yeah absolutely now joey when you go
uh when you do
road work when you're out there do you
get room service every day or no you
don't
you got to go out and see some air and
oxygen
some hotels they put you at they put you
in industrial parks
and it sucks because that hotel has
shifts on food and you got to eat that
shitty food that pisses me off uh-huh i
always try to opt for a hotel with a
civilization right
if i'm in vegas
since vegas is one of the only places
that gives you a food allowance uh-huh
i'll go out on the live and get room
service because it's a [ __ ] hike to
the elevator when they put me in vegas
no i mean
cleaning like when you do you have a
room service every day no cleaning
that's that's i don't want nobody coming
to my room that's what i'm getting at i
like sleep apnea machine
i got sensitivity stuff and i got my
computer so they don't pressure you like
hey what's going on in there why don't
you have service you know
they call sometimes and say
uh can we get you towels or anything or
if i need something i just give the girl
five bucks and i take two towels with a
bar of soap or whatever i need so i
shouldn't feel weirded out or pressured
no i don't let nobody in my [ __ ] room
they don't hotel i stay that that
actually called like three times and
they're like listen it's hotel policy
i said ain't nobody coming in my [ __ ]
room if she wants to come in my room i
gotta be in here it's not a thing of
trust i just don't want nobody in my
[ __ ] room gotcha so there's a lot of
guys like that a lot of people like i'm
like you don't have room service i mean
room cleaning i do like let me ask you
joey if you're on the road with your
wife will you because when i'm with
paula i will
there's a name for that you pick it up
and then you tuck the corner and then
you have to put it over it's got to have
a crease in the side uh hospital corners
all right you got to have all that [ __ ]
none i ain't doing no more hospital
corners i fluff out the sheets
i fluff the pillows i don't like getting
in bed and the pillows are [ __ ] up in
the night before it pisses me off
and it slows me down now i'm pissed off
again because nobody fluffed the [ __ ]
pillows now that's another half hour
before i fall asleep yeah i've been
making my bed recently it feels good
but there's a new change in my life but
you know here's the thing
when you're a comedian or you're a
go-getter or you're living day-to-day
it's like you feel different one day you
feel this way the other day you feel
next some days i'm inspired to do this
some days i'm not sometimes i'm eating
here sometimes i'm not it's just hard to
stay concerned i'm doing good stuff
don't get me wrong but it's hard to
really
you know you have to be brody
or is it oh it's a very deep question no
the question is like i look at my life
when i was unhealthy
and i look at my life when i'm healthy i
have a pattern
in the kitchen when i wake up when i
wake up i do a couple cbd drops
you know when i wake up in the morning
drink a cold glass of water with ice in
it that's a great to get my [ __ ]
stomach going you're supposed to then i
put the call for you then i take this
[ __ ] uh for your throat whatever the
[ __ ] that is that [ __ ] that vein in your
throat
a thyroid i gotta take a pill for that
before i eat
then after i pop that i make a [ __ ]
fruit smoothie with almond milk and a
bunch of fresh fruit and some frozen
fruit to keep it a little thicker you're
already ahead of the game okay and then
after that i [ __ ] do a cbd drop seven
drops in my mouth to break all the cans
in my body if there's some in there why
[ __ ] weight you know what i'm saying
then i [ __ ] spray my nose with the
antibiotics
the steroids
how often you have to do that twice a
day for how long
until i get the surgery on the 11th of
july okay
then i [ __ ] take a shower and wash my
[ __ ] whoa and then i smoke some more
dope you gotta eat my eggs my three
pieces of bacon and my one slice of
wheat toast
i don't eat egg whites i only eat like
yolks
you understand me i go right for the
heart of the chicken when i [ __ ] around
with that [ __ ] creamy white [ __ ] that
smells like dick
you know if i smell egg whites fried i
get sick
yeah i can't even smell them no more
so you that's your routine right now
yeah so oh i switch it up i get oatmeal
with coconut milk
who's better than uncle joey i like that
that's when i walk my daughter to school
oh i gotta jump at nine o'clock i'm out
there exercising the lungs maybe a half
a mile so i put a mile in
i do my breathing exercises and my walk
dr belize's book i do the breathing and
the walking breathing exercises
then i get home i write for an hour and
i put my gi on i go to jiu jitsu
and i get beat up by young kids like i
do sit ups and push-ups
and i figure every time i go i got to do
25 push-ups so if i go three times we
can do 75 push-ups a week you know
this is [ __ ] that you don't do at home i
do that right i get beat up i work my
cardio
i get my core stronger okay
i drink a little protein
activity 26 grams of protein refuse my
electrolytes yep
i also take a lime and i freeze it and i
[ __ ] grind the lime core because it's
good for your [ __ ] what's that thing
in the [ __ ] people die men die from
prostate prostate it's good
both of them so you shave the line that
powder shave your [ __ ] i mean the
lime
you shave the lime that little [ __ ]
there's a lot of water powder that comes
out of that lime yeah i'm just putting
you do all this you put in your fruit
smoothie oh it's now it's in the
smoothie because i look in the living
room and i see a little girl yeah
and i at least got to be around till
she's 12 to navigate her [ __ ] cuban
mind to awake those spirits you
understand me
i can't have a walking around half mo
mode
you know it's a different game i got to
prepare for [ __ ] 2020. i ain't got
time to [ __ ] around
so if i could live until she's 12 i'm
good if i could walk it down the aisle
that's [ __ ] better
if i could see it graduate college
that's better the way i look at it every
little bit helps
yeah every little bit helps i'm not
dying for nothing no more when we were
young we'd die for stuff we'd stay up
all night to catch a plane
you know how bad that is for you
to stay up all night to catch a plane
no you know somebody's told me that
after i have the surgery i'm gonna lose
50 pounds off the bat
what surgery are you getting my nose and
they said this is why because he goes
when i first met you never breathed out
of your nose
and since your body wasn't getting
oxygen that's what got you hungry that's
what made you eat all those sweets
because once you started breathing and
working out the weight fell off but i
could still hear the
[ __ ] in your nose
because i was double taking on i'm like
maybe i shouldn't have the surgery
and he goes no you gotta have the
surgery your life's gonna change
completely
because now you're getting more fresh
oxygen which makes your body and i test
i test my
ph every morning
and it's really amazing because like dr
billy said when i leave sometimes it's
[ __ ] up my ph
but after the walk and the breathing
exercises when i come back
perfect
6.5 you go to amazon you buy the ph
strips they send you a row and you do it
every morning
and i never do it after jiu jitsu i
wonder what it is after just because you
sweat [ __ ] gallons with that guy on
yeah my ghee is outside right now i
looked at my [ __ ] pants from your
back how much is on your back never mind
the strip from your ass your [ __ ]
sweats your balls you wash the uniform
every bro every day it's in the laundry
right now you have a washer and dryer
everything yeah see i i don't i hang it
up i i have to leave my knee pads
outside even [ __ ] don't get that
knee pads they're sweating
that's how sweaty you get your knee pads
at jiu jitsu even people who suck [ __ ]
for 12 hours
they don't couldn't get their knee pads
just [ __ ] up and i think that's really
good just the sweat part of you you've
got to break the sweat that's what
matthew mcconaughey says break his sweat
every day it's like when i do
kettlebells i wouldn't i wouldn't go
home till i saw the sweat down here
like i won't go home from a workout
until this is all covered with sweat
gotcha whenever it's the elliptical
machine punch in the bag whenever i did
all that [ __ ] on my own that was my goal
i wanna i wanna smell some of the
reefing
coming through the pores coming through
the pores you know i want to smell some
of this [ __ ] apple cider vinegar that's
what i take that cleans it all out i can
smell it like go through my pores i've
been taking that with some uh orange
juice i down it's supposed to be really
good for you the the mothers brag mother
of the earth
apple cider vinegar they say it's good
for just detoxing i mean every
everything everything so i take that i
do need to drink more water go ahead you
were talking earlier about how uh
important baseball is to you like would
it change if you couldn't
if you couldn't pitch like cause you do
that a lot i watch you on periscope you
throw like well that was a one-time deal
actually that was well no no but you you
practice baseball's in my blood right
like if you couldn't do that how would
that change you
i mean it would be uh
let me see didn't see that question is
coming out from left field um it's about
sweating because like that's i think
that's what you do a lot to exercise
like that's what i was imagining like
if i couldn't play baseball mm-hmm well
i'd be depressed i mean i like throwing
the baseball
i did i did play baseball the other day
do you have a bounce back in your yard
or anything anywhere like that you could
just throw a bounce back one of those
things from the 80s i do i do have a
bounce back but i need to put it
together with a uh
with a screwdriver sometimes i go down
what i would do is go down to the high
school north hollywood high school or
resida and i'd throw the ball against
the wall because i it's hard to get a
catcher you know like get a guy to catch
you but my friend who's a coach with the
cubs uh he was a major he's a major
league baseball coach so we would always
throw i play catch with him before
spring training so i always get like a
month or six weeks in of like good
professional catch with like a guy who
knows what he's doing because if find a
comedian to play catch with sometimes
it's hard like they don't know what
they're doing it's not as fun but when
you're with the pro
boom boom boom get a good workout
so for me yeah i'll go and throw it
against the high school or i'll do the
the tubing i train like a pitcher but
i'm not actually pitching in games and
but this game this charity game came up
and uh
i had been practicing i kind of in my i
did throw a bullpen this year on the
side i still i still have it i'm not
but i didn't think i'd play in a game i
didn't think i would play this game
cannot came out of nowhere as a charity
game that a former major league baseball
player put on so at the last minute they
said brody you want to go pitch i go
i'll try
because i just played catch and i threw
a bullpen uh in spring training and i
pitched one inning then i went to two to
three to four and it's like i look
pretty good
so
this is kind of like
it's good for video it's good for me i
enjoyed doing it i was like wow i got a
kick out of doing it my world is
whatever keeps you happy
that's it
yeah but it doesn't pay my bills who
gives a [ __ ] well it's you know
i think a lot of people could do what i
do listen how many people but they have
kids how many people have a job
that can pay their bills but hate that
job hate their wife and they hate going
home
sometimes money isn't [ __ ] everything
well money is not everything i just want
enough to survive to keep doing
periscopes
and you're happy as [ __ ] you know that's
what a hobby is to take your mind away
from the everyday drumming two
absolutely
you think i'm gonna be a world champion
jiu jitsu guy at 53 is that why you
think i go to jiu jitsu do you think i'm
doing this to fight i do this
so for one hour it belongs to me
that's all i want from the day one hour
that belongs to me that i could i'm my
own [ __ ] nazi i'm my own hitler i'm
my own fidel castro on my own
i'm my own dictator yeah for one hour i
leave the phone in the car
you know what that audition could suck
your dick
if
something the only thing that lingers is
your mind as a man is that something bad
can happen you can't be there to help
somebody you know on your phone
but when you're training jiu jitsu if
you're training you can't check your
phone until every 30 minutes so you'll
get water anyway so something bad can
happen i don't leave my phone in the car
because i enjoy it i kept this in the
dugout i checked between innings was
pretty cool all right whatever but i'm
saying when you work out like that's
your own one hour if that's what keeps
you funny
is pitching against a [ __ ] war at
north hollywood high on periscope
on periscope then so be it that's what
people understand i believe in keeping
people's power dry
people got to learn how to keep their
own [ __ ] powder dry
what you mean keeps your palate dry go
off the deep end in whatever way you
describe it whether it's alcohol drugs
any [ __ ] way losing your temper
yelling at your wife anything that
controls that [ __ ]
is keeping your powder dry if it means
that you go to a [ __ ] circus and hang
upside down for an hour with monkey [ __ ]
in your face and you come back and tell
me but you got a smile on your face
who gives a [ __ ] there's times i go on
stage i don't want to go on stage i
don't care what they're [ __ ] paying
me
you know that but there's times i wake
up my back hurts
i feel like [ __ ] and i say to myself i'm
not going to jiu jitsu like one second
if i don't go to jiu jitsu my whole
day's gonna be ruined do kettlebells
instead well bingo but i understand and
that's what i was doing for a long time
i would cut the sh
i would take a shortcut with the
kettlebell there you go and not go to
jiu jitsu no oh i want to go to jiu
jitsu i'm treating this like being an
open mic
remember when you were an open mic
regardless of what was going on
you did that spot yep whether you felt
bad whether your cat was dying you don't
give a [ __ ] we would go that was
guaranteed every guarantee monday
tuesday i had to apply the same
technology to jiu jitsu
because dog when i wake up in the
morning i'm overwhelmed
because me too stand up how do you your
agent talking to you about stupid offers
your wife talking to you about you saw a
cabin and whatever it's just ridiculous
so for one hour
i just disappear
i don't give a [ __ ] i get on the phone i
say i missed six messages and i [ __ ]
love it could you do two hours
disappear for two hours
two hours a little tough in my world
because of the baby i try and disappear
for about 24 hours
how's that work out for you not too
[ __ ] good
not too [ __ ] good i could find if i
could [ __ ] find you can't disappear
that good
no
um yeah it's it's it's look i like doing
the baseball i but of course i would
like to do it where i'm getting paid for
it somehow i'm all you know when i do
stuff on periscope when you become a
[ __ ] announcer
why don't you become a manager
it's not that easy who said
who said i'm a pitcher joey i know
you're a pitcher what the [ __ ] do you
think half the announcers are
ex-baseball players good point
okay so it's gonna be up to the plate
you could work six months a year making
nothing the other half go on the [ __ ]
road i should be an announcer are you
[ __ ] crazy with a suit on they take
care of you you go to different cities
then it becomes the point where let's
say you go to chicago for a three-night
stand yeah you do comedy one night
yeah cause it's a great game
by the way i'll be doing stand up later
tonight after the game that's it and
people you'll sell out every [ __ ]
place you'll do theaters yep baseball
players will come see you people take
pictures it becomes a national [ __ ]
riot brodie stevens why don't you
[ __ ] become an announcer you got into
fox i need to do i do i need you
tremendous push i'm not pushing you say
listen start me up with college [ __ ]
games you got girls in college that are
coming out of high school announcing i
should be doing i've already experienced
baseball and the new dick fight towel
and with personality
vin scully is retiring soon yeah what
the [ __ ] you're sitting on the sidelines
you like baseball you said that's what
i'm trying to do listen brody the
baseball you're 46. obviously you're not
going to mention the world series
so
so you got to make it a different way
what's the best way to be around
pitchers to be around baseball you're
going to be
at the [ __ ]
at the city where chicago you're going
to be in san diego for the weekend i'm
sure they're going to let you on to
batting practice to talk to the guys
yeah throw your teeth they're going to
do a segment yeah throw these minutes
exactly what the [ __ ] do you think
you're dealing with
you think you got some novices you were
there at best damn sports show you were
there you were there i was there with
you on public access television in
seattle
95 in seattle yes you were 19 21 years
ago so you're looking at two morons
right now thinking look at these two
[ __ ] momos don't know whatever but
you know what you can't take away from
this
21 years of comedy
yep going for it that's what so many
people
can't understand when nate diaz fought
conor mcgregor
i had a bait bet nate diaz
i go to jiu jitsu i see
what the level of a black belt is
when they're a real black belt with a
stripe or two
and they're in the [ __ ] game i lay on
top of them and they're not even
breathing heavy they're down there
[ __ ] making a call to that girlfriend
and [ __ ] let's not call you back i got a
three pound guy on top of me let me
[ __ ] flip him
it's amazing
but you know why i had that trust in him
because he's been doing it for 15 years
when you have somebody listen if i came
to la
and i got made a regular at the store
and for 20 years i did my spots and
after 20 years
i wanted to raise my daughter and i got
out of it and people made fun of me and
laughed at me you know what you can't
take away from me bro i was at that
store for 20 years i got to be worth
some
that's worth something i had to follow
paul mooney you were there with me
you know you got to follow david tell
you got to follow people
and it's an experience
the experience that we got starting with
seattle we were there on monday nights
with mitch hedberg and the kid who died
from the pills down in [ __ ] texas and
how many people have we seen coming down
in this business bro he was still in it
yeah and you know people say oh well you
should be the kevin hart i shouldn't be
a lot of things i should be in jail
i should be dead i should be in a rehab
[ __ ] right now
but no i'm in [ __ ] studio city with
brodie stevens yeah still banging that
pushing and my little [ __ ] jew
[ __ ]
lee syad over there look at him on 900
milligrams of pure red star thc
meanwhile you're sitting at home going
what am i going to do with my life
literally eating 900 milligrams at four
o'clock [ __ ] pacific time i kind of
want to take a drug test just to see
what comes back like do you think they
do percentages
you know what's gonna come back you got
liz's blood from those tacos you eat
over on magnolia
there's no lizard tacos it's he okay
he always tell and any place i go brody
he likes to mess with me because i get i
get in my own head so like when i go to
get dumplings he says look for stray
cats there's no cats in korea town and
then for this he says that this dumpling
there's a taco place has lizard meat
they got arrested no they didn't there's
google google has every arrest ever so
you gotta google like a weird animal
they got the
when i first moved to [ __ ] up here i
said what a [ __ ] school i go to the
ymca walk around the corner and go to
that taco place and the whole room went
you don't want to go to taco place
and i'm like why not it's a bat and in
fact i lied because i had gone over that
one time
and i took terry one time she said i
don't like this the meat looks kind of
weird
and that's when i went back to the wine
i asked the girl how come you guys
looked at me always because that place
got arrested for they had like [ __ ]
uh
what's that lizard no what's that thing
with the thorns on it oh not a porcupine
but the other one amarillo amarillo
one of those [ __ ] things armadillo
armadillo meeting there oh gross and
they got arrested they deported the
mexicans who were selling armadillo meat
even if they don't have it no more they
still got the knives that cut the
armadillo i'm saying you don't want to
be involved with that [ __ ] lee then you
took your father he got poisoned he
didn't
would you take him the taco place
no no a different taco place we had a
lizard burrito no he he had a good a
couple tacos he just wasn't taking it's
always good on the way down because
you're stoned you don't know what you're
eating listen me you think the weird
you're like everybody says it's good so
you're just eating it
something don't taste right oh
lizard would you eat lizard brodie no
i'm not i'm i like chicken
steak i'll eat pork that's a good idea
bacon and mashed potatoes it's time for
you to take him a great direction you
would be a great baseball announcer
right i think i could work on it
yeah i could do it
i just need to put the energy out there
and uh make that happen put my suit on
look good i think it would be it would
be funny i did the baseball all-star
game last year with the periscope for
comedy central i did that i'm actually
trying to maybe
one day
to maybe i like coaching being a they do
have mental skills coaches and sports in
baseball they have
actually the dodgers actually a few
years ago had a positive energy coach
they had a they had a guy
uh a russian guy out in malibu who
thought good positive energy for the
dodgers and he made and they paid him
like several hundred thousand dollars a
year that was the last owner of the
dodgers but they do have mental skills
coaches and i'm that kind of guys i'm
not a psychologist necessarily but i
played baseball i'm a good guy i know
psychology bring a little bit of humor
guys like having me around there's a job
there for it i like being around
baseball i get excited being around bait
it's in my blood so would they come see
you in an office
would you go up to the field to them and
go hey probably be on the field the
other night you went over three is this
something you want to talk about
yeah guys are comfortable talking to me
like you know they're comfortable
confiding in me
so
and
i think there's a there's there's
something to that i know i know
when i played baseball at arizona state
we learned all that psychology all the
bait that's what i put into being
positive energy yes because it does work
it is mathematics in play it does work
and then also
just being at best damn sports
show applying that being positive
because when you didn't bring good
energy guys were slouching show the show
wouldn't be as funny lights would go off
things would break but when i got those
kids on that show to sit up and pay
attention these football guys and made
it for a better show
so i learned about
especially with warm-up how energy comes
into play how it affects everything
makes it for a better show
so
i was able to work with all these kids
all the high schools all the community
colleges on
you know sitting up and you know they
like me slouching i go look there's
michael irving right there he's won
three super bowls michael strahan two
super bowls you want to talk to him
they're not coming over here because
you're not bringing it let's go you know
these kids would come in like goofing
around so
but it really
those years at best damn sports show
those thousand shows really i was able
to apply the sports
with
show business somewhat but you know what
you can only do that so far hollywood's
more sensitive now the things i didn't
warm up back then i can't get away with
now because these kids complain
they'll go on facebook or they'll write
an email whereas before you could yell
at them they didn't nobody had anything
so warm up the last three warm-up gigs
i've done have not been fun because
they just
they
they don't want to cause waves they're
just you know it's like the audiences
are bad and uh
i care about the show people don't care
about the show i've always cared about
the show i cared about chelsea i cared
about best damn sports show these shows
so these last few shows that i that i
cared about that i'm not at anymore
people don't talk about them
where i put my buzz in my energy good
things happen so i stopped doing that
warm up i started focus on the comedy
store it's a hot club i started focus on
periscope boom prince of periscope
so it's like whenever you put i put my
mind to something
i can do it so at the end of the day
nobody to blame there's no blame there's
no negativity but i i i feel like i'm in
a good position i just i'm just shut i'm
shifting gears going from being that
warm-up guy to being the man to be in
that man and it there's a big momentum
shift that takes a year or two to really
like get everything going and then
pushing in that direction a couple weeks
ago i went to the store dick van dyke
was there to see you yeah dick van dyke
has been to my shows great guy that that
feels good to know that another night i
went there some dodger dudes were there
to see you some old dudes were there
dodgers have been there your shirts and
[ __ ] like that yeah you never you have
uh people are out there supporting you i
mean you have great support you come
along you know last couple of months
i've been sitting here with lee and
josh wolf came on you come on brad came
on a couple all the comics
that i've known
for years and i'm looking at you and i'm
remembering you in seattle me breaking
your balls about the [ __ ] show
and what did you say the other day that
you like you were driving his car down
to tacoma
volvo
volvo
diesel station wagon and i was
in the back seat eating chinese food
chicken teriyaki from next door how good
was that chicken oh that was good they
cut it with a scissor oh my god lee you
would die the [ __ ] salad dressing oh
my god everything we were in there all
the time it was good this i ate chicken
teriyaki every [ __ ] day in seattle at
one point or another
six bucks
yeah it was like
yeah if that it was a deal they're
friendly you know not too friendly but
nice enough
friendly but not you know they still had
they're they're very korean or japanese
it was very it was right there in
downtown next to the uh comedy
underground and
then that show he went down to tacoma i
think it was a bunch of us and i for
some reason i just wanted to sit in the
back of the cars like hey you know and
it was just seattle was a cool it was a
cool
time to be there and
those late uh those summer nights it's
daylight out and it's just like kind of
cool and i'll get in the back in the
hatchback and
that was crazy joe he was like driving
he's speeding he questioned
listen what the [ __ ]
i love becca did that
but when becky says to me
you know i went to san diego i'm going
to take you to come back four hours i
want to smack you
because i could do it an hour 30 years
almost got to leave at 11 o'clock at
night so
i was telling him one day we're talking
that day and he's pissing me off he's
like [ __ ] baiting me like no you
cannot make it to gig hub
in an hour and a half i i've been down
there and it's taken me two hours i
think i got done in an hour
like i just did 90 there was no signs
there was no stop signs in my world how
normal people drive at the time there
was no license like i had no proof that
i had a license i was gonna like doing
but i had no paper license like i didn't
in those days the last thing i wanted on
me was id
so i never carried an idea i mean i got
id but i got it with the house
and they let me go nobody wants to take
you home to check your [ __ ] wallet so
you know i just was in a different
[ __ ] state of mind and i wanted to
show brody would take us down there
and it would take us an hour and a half
to get down
and we made it like [ __ ] an hour 15.
the other day i saw a picture tommy east
on facebook
tommy easter got banned from the comedy
store
and
he had called me up and he goes can you
get me back in and i talked to what's
his name he goes you know give it some
time
you know he [ __ ] bit slapped the made
guy up there he slipped that bit slapped
the [ __ ] whatever so
but i was i told him like the comedy
store is kind of weird for comics when
they come in yeah that they have to have
an experienced league i cannot describe
it to you
i can't write a book with a [ __ ]
if steven spielberg who's the author
who's the best author out there today
stephen king stephen king came over here
right now
i could sit with stephen king for a year
and couldn't describe to him what i'm
going to tell you right now i saw tommy
easter he's put a picture up of him with
five comics now for people who don't
know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
break it down for you
when you do calmly
somewhere else
beside new york and la
it's a different mindset
you get raised a different way
you're raised in an old-fashioned comedy
community the guy at the [ __ ] bar is
a cokehead
the guy that collects the tickets it's
an old school comic that did have a
heyday but he really ain't [ __ ]
but he knows the business you know
and when you watch the movie punchline
that's what made me jump on comedy it
was a [ __ ] dirty club in the middle
of new jersey
and uh and the comedy club manager
wanted to manage comics because he would
become a millionaire and blah blah it's
a greasy business but at the end
it's your fundamentals
it's your fundamentals
when you move to la as a comic or new
york as a comic you do not have
fundamentals
this kid in front of me right here
i used to torture him at monday nights
about his
he had a public what was it called uh
cable access cable access show
21 [ __ ] years ago so do you want to
question brody steven's resume
or any comics resume look at this
picture now right there there's six guys
that are herbs where the [ __ ] they are
they're stoned between the six of them
they probably got 22.50 on them
guess what when they're sitting in their
mansion 20 years from now counting
hundred dollar bills
they're gonna miss that time right there
because there's not a day that i get on
stage and i come off that stage at the
comedy store and i don't think of a
night at the underground
i cut my teeth at the el paso club i cut
my teeth in houston i cut i started the
denver comedy works but where i became a
comedian
and where i saw the best performance of
my life was at the comedy underground
you know laurie kilmartin is still
around town yeah i opened for laurie
kilmartin the first time
that to me
like i see laurie now she don't say
nothing and i don't you know whatever
people will get for different heads when
they come down here
till this day i see laurie and i would
cut her thumbnails
because she was the first headliner i
got the feature for right that's huge
becky that's huge i couldn't feature
nowhere else i moved to seattle i called
john fox he features me in september
lee you can't describe that one of the
best times i've ever had in my life was
that week of the comedy seattle comedy
competition oh yeah because then that
sunday we all went to seattle football
game with al triferis and the black kid
with the kidney problem from [ __ ]
portland oregon that he's i used to call
him
floyd floyd he lives in michigan now
there was 15 people hanging out all week
you know james inman and yeah you like
some guys
but for the most part you did like
everybody it didn't really matter we all
knew what it was you weren't gonna
[ __ ] be on a movie or do a movie with
eddie murphy but i learned so much
in that room that's the first room i
would do 22 minutes in
you know that's the first room where
ever improvised then
think of all the things we learned there
like that was our first
[ __ ] trial and error room
that's it that basement will lie in my
soul for the rest of my life and i got
all the respect for the comedy store and
i'll tell you how strong that basement
is that there's three of us in l.a right
now from the same class
[ __ ] rocking it
me you and josh wolf are still alive and
kicking
still alive and kicking down here you
know we crossed paths i crossed patrick
you're on the best damn sports show you
crossed paths with him on chelsea yeah
how could that be possible
because we learned the fundamentals
there the fundament did you see the
movie uh the 30 for 30.
with uh
jim valvano anybody seen that the black
kid that kept saying the math to high
school
i always thank coach wood because he did
what he taught us the fundamentals and
he showed the basketball game
championship level and the guy throws a
pass and he goes to retreat with one
hand he goes they lost the game why
bob wooden
fundamentals you never catch a cross
court pass with one hand you always
count you sit there go
you're [ __ ] right
championship college basketball game you
know
we have the fundamentals i mean i
learned everything in that club
yeah i learned about a three-person show
it wasn't a showcase club it was three
persons on the weekends you had the open
mics with the crowd you know it was kind
of a supporter tuesday was very
supportive you know 35 people 50 people
but wednesdays belong to us so either me
brody gavin josh wolf somebody else got
the door 70 of the door and we would
have to promote it and then we take the
money we give each other enough money to
get weed and then we go to that
restaurant mccormick and schmitz and get
the happy hour from 11 to [ __ ] two
they would have a hamburger happy hour
for two bucks they'd have a shrimp
cocktail for two bucks seattle was great
it was [ __ ] it was you know summers
in seattle whoa i got arrested six times
in 18 months you understand me it don't
get no better than that though
and it's amazing that you're here today
and i was on the phone with her
yesterday talking about ridiculousness
yeah energy's putting it out yeah i
learned that but you were the one who
also told me like because when you start
there
you get to a certain point like i made
it to where okay i was getting to do
guest spots and maybe host a show that's
about where i leveled off because you
know you come there they don't know you
it's like you they you
first impressions and i was fine with
that and i sold my t-shirts at the for
the seattle supersonics i just learned
to public speak that was my goal just
learned to public speak but after a few
years i felt like
i was done with that cable access i kind
of had my voice but i needed more but i
wasn't ready for la and you told me
go to new york now you joey was the one
to go to surf reality and that for me
was just like i didn't look back i went
to i went to new york and it was like
right away i felt like i told two people
go to new york you and mitch hedberg
because if i go to new york there's a
thousand people like me in new york
i'm going up against a thousand guidos
in new york
if i go to seattle there's nobody like
me in seattle there wasn't and in l.a
there's a few of us yeah
so you when you're a comic you want to
go where you're a novelty
you fight if you're a fat little jew
like lee you don't want to [ __ ] go to
new york because it's a thousand jews
right yeah yeah yeah they'll relate to
you so should i go like down south
no you'll get killed you know they'll
[ __ ] kill you at the midnight you
know
go to beaumont tell them i'm
jewish around i'll stab you with a knife
down there i was thinking orlando oh
they'll stab you down there too they
only want mickey mouse trust me but no
you would go to like uh michigan
[ __ ] well it's a cold
that's part of the [ __ ] that's what
builds the character
when i get in the car with you the gig
starts at eight
and we gotta leave at five
and we got enough money for a tank of
gas
and to stop a set depending on how much
gas we got we could stop with an hour
left and maybe get some deed
there was no head shots in the car
there was no agents coming to the show
nope it was just me and brodie brody
maybe brody had 18 minutes and he was
gonna feature
and maybe i had 32 minutes and i was in
the headline but guess what i don't give
a [ __ ] i need that 150
you know that's a bond you build
and that's something to see that
vulnerability that you remember forever
if you think i remember being on the
longest yard yeah it was great and i had
a good time no
i remember driving back from [ __ ]
riverside riverton wyoming with rick
kearns and he's drinking jack and cokes
like they're going out of style he's
behind the wheel telling stories and
smoking cigarettes and [ __ ] and the cars
going from [ __ ] one side to the other
that's when you remember a comic for the
rest of your [ __ ] life okay
you know i talk about that story with
him in the backseat because i remember
that for the rest of my life him yelling
in the back normal people don't drive
like this
you know and us howling he had his
[ __ ] alley
when i get out i'm going to call the
police this is kidnapping
yeah those are those are just great
crazy days and uh but
seattle was the perfect spot to be it
was just a hot spot
and
but then when i went to new york i
didn't i really never looked back you
know when you're in new york new york
doesn't even know that seattle exists
it's not even no not even uh
not even on it and this is this is the
funny thing that
i talk about this all the time that
there used to be a comedy newspaper the
san francisco scene at one time was so
big guys oh yeah in the mid 80s it was
so big i mean from margaret cho to bobby
slayton to there was so [ __ ] many
comics up there
and the the guy john fox who booked reno
he booked uh all those clubs the punch
lines he booked seattle comedy
underground he was a part owner on the
club he put out a publication they
interviewed but in the back of that they
would have every comedy club state by
state arizona california right
and they would have the logo for the
club and i remember that i would sit
there and look at that seattle logo
and i always had an inkling about
seattle this was weird guys that i
in 1970 [ __ ] six or seven or three
the seattle supersonics went to the
[ __ ] playoffs
and they were amazing they had a
basketball put a guy named uh downtown
freddie brown all right downtown freddie
brown this skit blew my mind
so you had to stay up late to watch
seattle was it yeah you had to stay
label
jersey yeah and i remember staying up
like lying to my mom like i'll be in bed
but watching the tv and they would show
this city seattle
he was drafted in 71. who downtown
freddie brown yes sir yeah but show a
video off okay what do i give a [ __ ]
about i don't know he was drafted
here no i'm looking for a picture
downtown freddie brown he was this short
little chubby guy
that drank beers on the bench
and popped dirty footers no he didn't he
drank beers on the street yes he [ __ ]
did in the brown bag and he also told
him he was going to play defense he said
that he said that he said listen you
need six seven points
so you saw you saw that i saw this in 77
whatever the [ __ ] was youtube it's right
up there
no i get that because when i was there
you go 1979 finals
okay for freddie brown 1979 finals game
five okay you know
this guy was a [ __ ] savage
look what he was built like and they're
playing the washington bullets
with fred with wes unseld
[ __ ] uh
oh my i mean they had a tremendous team
look at look at him
bam that's all he did lee when he shot
he did not miss
see he would always come in the second
quarter
they had uh jack sigma jack sick my dad
look at freddie bradley
look at him
that's all he did
he was money look at him that's all he
did he would tell him listen i don't
want to [ __ ] around put me in when you
need points i'll bang out [ __ ] 20
points and i don't want to play no more
was fun then it's fun again dawg i used
to stay up this was this was a
tremendous washington bullet [ __ ]
team
how old were you joey
15 14.
i would cry watching these things but
you know what it's a very bad bam
bam
like like nothing he don't miss look at
him little chubby black dude
he would
you know in the
he wouldn't get out of the game once
they walk three points coach time out
i'm done coach you know what the the
lakers in uh the 76ers and magic scored
40 seconds 46
42 points to in in 1970 let's look at
this one
luna
look at him he's on fire by himself
that's it now he calls it timeout what'd
i tell you seattle first lead of the
game he's out that's it he's causing
coach i had enough my lungs i gotta
smoke a cigarette and [ __ ] but the
lakers 76ers that game where magic
scored 42 points to clinch it that was
on tape delay that wasn't live that's
where basketball was that was on at like
11 30 p.m on channel two here in l.a it
was not live
that's where basketball was
wow so this game i'm sure wasn't live
you're watching a tape delay or
something
well yeah we'll hold it on late at night
look at freddie brown on the floor
that's it coach i can't he look put that
back he popped it they knocked him down
look at him watch this [ __ ] shot
louis lemoa
did i miss it or should i go back
further
all the way
watch one more so let's see if they show
the instant replay here
look they even play funky music
look at them tyson's culture where's my
beer right so that's what triggered uh
that's what you saw
i love the seattle thing i'm like
looking at this [ __ ] seattle thing
i'm going wow
there's some cool white people up there
i'm gonna go up there i heard about
what's his name was up there killing
chicks like i wonder what the [ __ ]
going on up there and then when i
watched goodfellas
in 91 he went to seattle i mean yeah
that's the facility so i'm like wait a
second there's gonna be something going
on with that
so that was one of my dreams to go to
seattle
i was like i gotta go see how i'm doing
[ __ ] comedy mom am i gonna get up
there
i get a road geek to michigan while i'm
in michigan i finish the [ __ ] delete
you ever love this one i forgot to tell
you about this one i'm not in michigan i
finished the show
and this girl a hot girl comes up to me
and says do you want to have a drink
with me and my friends i say yeah
i end up talking to her and her friends
i go i gotta go because they didn't have
weed or something i don't wanna sit here
with these [ __ ] stiffs
i go back to my room my friend goes
where you going i go i'm going back to
sleep thank you for coming to the show
he goes listen man
i can't drive her i'm hammered can she
stay the night with you this only
happens when you're a comedian
can she stay the night with you oh yeah
and i go what are you talking about
and she's like yeah i know you have two
beds you were talking about it would
that be a problem can i stay the night
we usually got a mini skirt on with
heels
and i'm like oh this is going to be a
long [ __ ] night we go back to the
room we watch a movie she stays on her
side but i stay on my side of bed
whatever
[ __ ] three hours later i wake up to
her on the phone crying with the
ex-boyfriend
he's telling me he's coming over to beat
me up oh [ __ ] she's saying that she
didn't [ __ ] me
she wakes me up and asked me that you
[ __ ] me and i'm like what the [ __ ] am i
waking up to here
you know it was [ __ ] so after all
this drama i go you know what after all
this drama you might as well [ __ ] me
oh wow oh you know me dawg i asked her
right out this is [ __ ] now you're
gonna have to give me a piece of that
[ __ ] ass yeah
and what'd you say
give me right now i'll suck your dick up
my house nice
so i gave it right home the other thing
i didn't know the house was two hours
away oh yeah it's a long drink so on the
way home i go listen dog you can't just
sit here like this and you can't smoke
cigarettes in my car
and she goes what can i trade you go
take your [ __ ] clothes off if you're
gonna smoke in my car she took her
clothes off oh god this chick was crazy
and i dug it i had been single i love
crazy women i'm like i gotta take a ride
this is tremendous went back to a house
and guess what went back to her house
i felt so bad guys i didn't have sex
with her
like i had such a good time with her
like she took me out of my funk like you
know what i'm saying like you know
sometimes when you're in your funk and
you just bump into somebody and at that
time i need a coke to do everything i
sat with this girl for three hours and i
didn't eat coke
i talked to her and at the end i go you
know what what am i gonna gain by trying
to [ __ ] this poor girl she's got this
idiot boyfriend i'm gonna cause more pro
i don't even know if he's outside with a
car
i don't know what the [ __ ] going on i
gotta talk i gotta in those days i had a
flare
a hanger and like a [ __ ] bb gun in my
car i you know i had nothing i had no
weapons no protection so i dropped her
off
i gave him my number guys
come on this hot girl is not gonna
[ __ ] call me back
i just tried to finger her on the drive
she's not gonna [ __ ] call me back
guess what she called me back
and she came to boulder she drove the
boat
she stayed in boulder for two weeks in
my basement with me
we cooked we went camping we had a
[ __ ] great time
and she says i'm going to meet my friend
in seattle
i'm going to get a job up there as a
stripper
and if you want to come up you come up
this is my [ __ ] dream
i'd love to go to [ __ ] seattle
i'm not going to do nothing here in
boulder all i'm going to do is kill my
ex-wife and end up going to jail that's
all i'm gonna do here that's the truth
of the matter and then i got banned from
the comedy works and it all fell i i
follow life life gives you their own
signal sometimes i got nothing here no
job i'm delivering chinese food and
selling coke
and trying to do kami and that that's
not going to last that's not going to
[ __ ] last you know you can get
gifts i [ __ ] drove up i did a triple
run
yeah that dropped me off like in a mile
a couple miles from portland he used to
have a room in vancouver and i drove all
night
and i moved them
and then things happened yeah
then things happen but
we live and we learn her and i still
talk
and you know what i got the comedy
college that i wanted
we were in seattle we did the contest
it was an education you know aisha
taylor came in fifth i came in sixth
i got no [ __ ] even aisha taylor who's
on all those shows she was up there with
us there i miss seattle it's one of my
towns i actually like think about i feel
like
just living up on queen anne above the
space needle that look out over the the
water because i was in arizona for five
years i went to school at arizona state
and i grew up here in the valley so i
wasn't around
rain or snow or anything like that so i
really did the fresh clean air was like
i needed that i needed i needed the arts
i needed to be around grunge even though
that was wrapping up but it was the name
of the cook at the [ __ ] underground
the young kid with the long hair that
looked like chris cornell
that became my brother at the end he
became my brother broke my heart i heard
he got married and became a born-again
christian and [ __ ] i forgot that dude
kept me alive the last three months in
seattle
i owe that kid in my life
i really do i can't remember what his
name is
he came down to la one time and i picked
up packages for him
he goes i'm gonna meet at the comedy
store and he called the next day cause
listen the girl i'm with she's not
partying she's the manager of the band
so i really can't party and i was upset
for like an hour i understood it but
then he never called again and i was and
then
josh went up there and bumped into him
yeah
josh do you remember the cook what i'm
talking about yeah i i do it
the fat mexican kid was a scumbag once
in a while he gave us free nachos and
[ __ ] yeah then there was the filipino
bartender upstairs it was a dick to us
anthony was a bartender upstairs the
filipino guy he died after we left
we had and at this bar bro bill was
downstairs bill was downstairs he would
do coke with the asian that was his
girlfriend i remember going there on a
monday night and the asian waitress
bill's girlfriend and bill had done
heroin
heroin the open mic started at eight and
the [ __ ] waitresses are like this at
the table
they're [ __ ] nodding and i had to get
the door guy who's on facebook now the
older guy with the long hand with the
glasses carl no a deflate clay clay just
hit me up on for he did yeah about a
month ago he's living somewhere in
[ __ ] bangladesh good guy clay clay's
like you got to wake up he came to me
later can you believe these people did
[ __ ] heroin before work this is how
crazy this was
then we used to go to club named giggles
and torment them
terry terry no terry taylor wouldn't let
me in the bar the guy before the guy
before i tormented the vietnam vet that
was a pilot yeah i i didn't really know
him
he would always like comment on
everybody's act right but he would
comment on you but i would be clean when
he came in the room when he left the
room i would work dirty right he would
blame it on the other comic i'm getting
complaints
somebody's working dirty behind my back
who who's cursing on stage
and he went after the track guy one day
brad upton brad upton brad i'm just like
can you believe this i'm the cleanest
guy in america this guy's accusing me of
cursing because of you and brad's not a
rat right brad upton such a solid
[ __ ] guy i just can't believe that
was that guy's name
i can't believe that we're still here
brody doing comments really i figured by
now look look how many people gave up i
don't know what i'm going to be doing in
a year from now
but go who gave up go ahead i don't want
how many people that we do comedy
without around doing comedy no more
there's a lot more of us that aren't
doing comedy than a lot the kid with the
handcuff on his wrist he killed himself
was that jeff masterson oh my god you
got a memory of the hog no i know that
jeff master rita hoe died right okay
rita oh died did you ever get into a
fist fight with rito no did she ever
yell at you
not really did you like it did you talk
to her she was on uh our cable access
show
rita did she show you her dick in the
jar it's in a jar right it's like in a
mason jar told you lee
i don't think you ever told me that why
she kept her penis in a jar that was the
original transgender
20 years ago
we were already banging it out with a
transgender
some of the best [ __ ] laughs i ever
got with that [ __ ] transgender but
seattle comedy was about you know rico
the fat black guy that he i told him to
pick me up when the cops were looking
for me were you going
the [ __ ] spider on his face you can't
write this james hennigan james hennigan
the old guy left his wife at 50 to start
stand-up comedy kermit a po herman appio
who won the seattle comedy competition i
remember him when i was a host vince
valenzuela vince is here he's down in
l.a yeah he's insane he's in santa
monica he's on facebook oh okay i just
saw he put something out there and i'm
like i listen i've forgotten all about
as well
i got to invisible as well like i just
forgot about him it happened sometimes
vince valenzuela was the first person i
ever did moscow i the hallway
i've been there
on a saturday we drove
and they would send us those tequila
shots those [ __ ]
prairie farts with the tabasco in them
yeah [ __ ] holy
really what you [ __ ] missed
was that a rough room moscow or were
they yeah they were college kids it was
the universe it was washington state i
did it a few times i saw the quarter
back up there before he went to new
england lee
i saw him up there one day at the
airport drew bledsoe drew bledsoe
i did that room with josh uh yeah like
todd sawyer and
troy is downhills and todd sawyer is
down here he's a writer for somebody i
think he's overseas i think he's like in
uh he's in like thailand now is he okay
maybe kelly moran he passed away passed
away the girl the wife is still here
val meyers myers is still in la um al
fox alpha i don't know where al fox is
he's still maybe up there yoshi texting
me today i know that [ __ ] the black
kid's still doing comedy floyd no count
hopkins the third count hopkins a third
yeah i know he's still doing it's just
amazing chazz abelin i don't remember he
was friends with uh he was friends with
mitch hedberg
i remember chaz now okay yeah he's is he
still in town
i don't i think he's not there wally
glenn
um ron reed
carl warmer hoeven we learned a lot up
in seattle that's why i worked at that
club i i learned about seeding the clubs
i learned about the restaurant i learned
about the bartender i learned all about
seattle i learned about everything about
comedy at that level i just wanted to
learn to talk and i was so nervous
just speaking on camera i mean off the
the off mic the you know doing the
announcements but clay taught me a lot
about working the door but i was never
i didn't like love it i knew that i had
to do it i had to educate myself i knew
it would be good for me if you come to
la
i know for a fact
that there's a set that i got on one
time but i had no idea what i was doing
until this [ __ ] day that casting
director's mad at me he's so [ __ ] mad
at me that about a year ago i got
contacted
by a cast uh uh the star of this [ __ ]
stupid show on youtube was when youtube
was buying shows
and he said he wanted to cast me for
three days he goes the casting director
is going to call you this guy never
called me again it hurt the [ __ ] out of
my feelings
one day i'm in hollywood i bump into him
at the doctor's office saying can i talk
to you for a second how long are we
gonna [ __ ] friends
like well you never call me he's like
listen man i don't know what you did but
that dude that refused to have you on
the [ __ ] thing do you know wiley
because i didn't know how to step on the
line i didn't know how to
when they said action
i didn't know any of that stuff it set
me back so much that monday i had to
borrow 500
from josh wolfe to get into an acting
class
i'm not ashamed to say that's how
bothered i was from my performance
but
when i lived in seattle
somebody got me a job laura crocker god
bless her soul got me a job
doing industrials on saturdays they gave
you a hundred and a quarter lead for
four hours of work but it's like a video
for sony
and the guy's talking hi my name is
lisad here at sony and it's me and you
walking with boxers making believe
so at least you watch you know i was
never an extra
but i did those industrials
so you understand i'm trying to say to
you people by doing those things in
seattle nobody ever yelled at me
because
you know when i came down here i did
basketball and i didn't really know what
i was doing i did a couple things i
didn't know what i was doing but people
phil jan and people were nice on this
particular thing i did
the people were just scumbags
they didn't like me from the minute i
walked in there and now i didn't know
what i was doing i'm a [ __ ] comic
guys the guy hired me seeing me at the
[ __ ] comedy store the guy cast a
thousand [ __ ] movies he knows what
he's doing just tell me where to step
and what to do the people were just
scumbags
so but if i would have had that
opportunity in seattle to shoot a short
film in seattle or something i would
have known that action you're following
me and that's the point of this whole
thing that
the reason why maybe we're here is
because by the time we got here we were
seasoned already we knew our way around
the [ __ ] thing yeah that's why i did
that cable access i got i was able to do
live television
and see what would stick and then you
you get feedback that week or people
come up to you on the street hey brody
hey tanner we love your show we love
when you do that we love when you do
that we did it all in seattle and we did
crazy stuff you know if people unearth
those tapes it'd be kind of embarrassing
but people still have them people have
the tapes
yeah somebody on earth won a couple of
years ago i saw it online i was laughing
but we would get we would get fan mail
and the reason why i did it is like
those other guys had that tv show the
heckler line jeff masterson all these
guys and they had a crew
and they were popular i was going i
could do this i think
but i didn't have all these friends for
a crew and then right after that they
had this hotline studio which was about
the size of this room with two cameras
and you didn't have to have a crew it
was just you with you take a 30 minute
class and then you're set and then i did
that i felt like i could get practice
being on tv no one's you know and i just
built up on that and
i just went that way it just like i just
again that's kind of how i do everything
like i kind of do it you do what feels
right and then if you get feedback like
this is good this is good and you keep
doing it
so
seattle was great for all that the cable
access selling t-shirts for the seattle
supersonics that kind of stuff doing the
whole comedy underground but after
two and a half years you hit that
plateau there you go i'm ready for that
next thing but
i'm not ready for la
i always wanted to go to new york
so my friend got the job with the
yankees
joey said go out there this was before
the internet so i'm researching
everything go to surf reality that's
where i went sunday nights boom because
now you're going from four to five
minutes maybe to eight minutes
guaranteed and you're right there and
and i would just do that
i would do sundays and wednesdays and i
became a tour guide at radio city music
hall and then i just fed off the energy
of new york and was worked on being
myself
you know they weren't new york wasn't
intimidated by a
a guy with you know loud you know was
like normal so
then i was there in new york for three
years and at that point i felt i was
ready to come back to la but you got to
go away see i see these guys and i go
you got to go on the road got to go away
go away somewhere
and come back when you're wanted
even when i went even when i went when i
came to la my second year i disappeared
for 11 months
i basically lived off boxes on the road
and i sent clothes home and i'd sell cds
on the road and buy new cds it was
[ __ ] crazy i had a system down and
all i would have to do on monday was
call like three or four bookers
and i would book the year but i would
live off fallouts during the week i had
roger paul i had the guy in michigan i
must have six guys across the country
that i would call and go hey man if
there's a fallen i'm right here and
people would [ __ ] call me back by
wednesday and go drive up to
you know uh i don't even [ __ ] know
anymore he's crazy roger paul had a lot
of gigs we did baltimore you know he got
me a gig one time on a bus
a tour guide type doing commie on the
bus and [ __ ] you know you're just
learning
the ropes what happens is if you don't
have that peace
and you come out here and let's pretend
that you're good looking or your
girlfriend helps you write eight minutes
and also when you get a little fame with
18 minutes they're going to throw these
things at you and you're not going to be
[ __ ] prepared and that's what people
came on they give up on you
because they assume you know these
things
they assume you know these things listen
i don't [ __ ] hate acting class but
you gotta hit acting class for 60 days
just to get the ropes and see what the
[ __ ] people are talking about so you
don't stare at them like a [ __ ]
stranger because you could be the best
actor in the world and if you're holding
up the set or or something like that
people are going to get pissed and you
could be replaced time is money yeah
listen time is [ __ ] money
you know they tell you all this [ __ ] you
know well you could live in new york
just when they call you for an audition
fly in really
really like they're going gonna wait for
you to call [ __ ] jet blue and
schedule your trip around
it's uh i'm just really happy to see
that you're still doing it i need to
take acting classes by the way well
right now there's not that many [ __ ]
auditions the best thing you can do is
get together with four guys
four comics and go listen 7 30 at night
tuesdays from 7 30 to 8 weeks gonna do a
[ __ ] scene
that's it and it's all up to you guys
the first guy who don't show up that's
it don't come back and get another guy
that's how you do it for you guys to pay
somebody at this point listen man we got
you're at the store every night
you're at the store every night that's
the best [ __ ] that's good training
right there
[ __ ] yeah that's the best that's why
harrison ford don't let comics in his
movies because our timing is that much
[ __ ] better dawg
corey mack i love you [ __ ]
gray on sension dead squad mufc
shane cheverez brett malin chet rogers
tal yaffi
and bob lalingus always in my [ __ ]
heart as long as ooky spooky's lurking
and
bobby and [ __ ] christina down in
austin texas posting [ __ ] pictures of
food and whatnot lisa what's on your
mind how you feeling from 900 milligrams
of heavy duty boy today i'm feeling
pretty hot you're having a good week
yeah training you're back
when is mama leaving why does she take
the test she sells like a month and a
half what do you got this weekend ladies
saying
this um i think i might be going to see
tom segura in irvine
but other than that
what night is that maybe saturday
it's very nice but um i was actually
wondering
because i don't know if you can say it's
seattle but both of you are people
who
are very unique a lot of times when you
go to the store or the laugh factory
comics will kind of blend together
but you'll always remember
brody always remembered joey like is
that from seattle or like where does
that come from because not everyone has
it i mean maybe i don't know
seattle probably had something to do
with it but because bro like brody my
girlfriend got us
tickets to the show in irvine uh
the oddball tour
and those are
in theory the best comedians in the
world and you were
running the uh side show and then you
you hosted on the main show yeah and my
girlfriend at the end of the night and
we still talk about you because you
always pop up on periscope you were like
you were the highlight of the night out
of the
a-list well comics yeah that was one of
my better shows thank you yeah it was uh
you know a lot of it yeah just putting
out energy i think we had some really
good people back in the day some fun
comedians that
it was a good creative scene and uh like
i said cable access for me and just push
pushing each other i mean and i don't
know maybe every other city everyone had
their little scene but i think seattle
was was different it was probably right
up there with like a san francisco going
to boston at its time
it was my worldly i had some place i had
two places to go home i had three places
to go on monday night
i had two places to go on tuesday night
i don't know where we went on wednesday
night tacoma we we no tacoma was monday
nights then on wednesdays there was a
road there was a bar we used to go it up
to that town where all the boats landed
and then i know sunday was bellingham
but that was a completely different
thing i mean during the week and then
laura crocker booked a bunch of gigs we
used to do comedy
and
but i'll tell you who i had one of the
best nights of my life what was that
[ __ ] transgender chick rita oh
all right so this is going to take your
[ __ ] deep i get into a [ __ ]
fist fight with my girlfriend and her
ex-boyfriend and they throw me in jail i
come out i'm living with rita oh in her
spare bedroom do you remember that buddy
i knew you had some pro i i don't
remember you specifically living with
her yeah i had that i had like i had
spent three weeks with rita oh
and rita on top of being a transgender
comedian
you know
you [ __ ]
read the papers or read your people
magazine you make your opinions about
transgender people
i was around a transgender person for 18
months and i learned
a lot
you know what i [ __ ] learned man
she was very nice right out first of all
rita all
got pills from the government for her
transgender issues and she pretty much
sold them
she snorted blow she was a [ __ ]
she would drink
three pints
of vodka a day
two pints of vodka a day like her
breakfast was orange houston black god
bless her soul
because whatever she was she was very
good to me
she uh
you know she was a man right um and she
became a woman she was half japanese
have something and she cut her dick off
and put in a jar i mean she didn't cut a
dick off but you know they did it at the
farm whatever the [ __ ] they do it yeah
and she kept her dick in the jar did she
really bring it on the show brody
stevens are you breaking my balls i i
did not see it on the show but i did
hear that dick was in his jaw yes
because she told me it was in the safe
she goes i have a safe and i have it
hidden in there i don't think she took
it out of the [ __ ] sale is it like
like floating and was safe in the
refrigerator i don't [ __ ] know i
never even wanna [ __ ] formaldehyde why
would i wanna see somebody's dick in a
jar that's the last thing i wanna see so
i never i never even let her go there
you don't wanna know how big it is no
she was tiny he was tiny yeah he was
small she was small dorito was five foot
two and she would talk with that these
voices was a soft voice but then she'd
go again
yeah get away from my nachos and then
she'd do that for you she got what are
you [ __ ] guys doing you're [ __ ]
laughing about me because she had a wig
you know she wasn't the best looking
[ __ ] little [ __ ] you ever seen
she looked like a little leprechaun god
forbid me i'm seeing her face right now
yeah and she had like fake eyebrows you
know it was just a nightmare and she was
five foot two but she wear heels for
somebody who was six foot five yeah so
she would walk like really slow yeah
she'd say what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you you know like she was with her
cigarette with the cigarette and [ __ ]
but the whole day she'd be drinking and
what people don't know that i learned
was that i don't know how to say this
without offending until they come back
to bite me in the ass don't say it joey
i would give i would only be she was
done
well i had a ton of conversations with
her
because when she switched
she thought she made a mistake
what do you mean that's what made her
drink
and that's what the world don't know
that once they make that jump there's
problems the rate of suicide is really
[ __ ] high that's what america doesn't
know all this thing that's going on
right now like
it's it's it's a tough thing that
happens with transgenders and we i got
to know her you know i talked to her
she'd tell me your problems but the best
league
the best if i go comedy nights pound for
pound one of the best nights there was
somebody put together a comedy show
in a town about 15 minutes from the
underground
basalt but something bad so me and
joshua awful
no i mean that's what a mexican
restaurant was me and josh wolfe lived
up there with mark madison
bat something anyway somebody put
together a show the conditions of the
show were ballard ballard the conditions
of the show were
we couldn't curse
that was the conditions every week every
week there was drama
every week somebody and the owner would
stand
10 feet from the [ __ ] stage and as
soon as you cursed
he would walk on stage take the
microphone from you and say okay good
night ladies and gentlemen comedy show
is over and you start arguing with him
on stage come on i just said [ __ ] i told
you no cursing and you'd be like come on
i just said [ __ ] give me the mic back
okay people okay one more chance
he's not gonna curse thank you
drink specials 299 and he go to the side
and all of a sudden you do two more
minutes and you lay a [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay
castle that's it everybody out so
every time he'd see us walking on
wednesday he pulled us aside
listen guys tonight i got a family here
i got my sister-in-law's family the kids
are here no cursing we'd all look at
each other like watch this
so
i cursed somebody else cursed he's
threatening to cancel the show we put
rita oh up there uh-oh and she goes up
there and she's bombing
and finally she just [ __ ] snaps
and says what do you have to do show you
my dick in a jar you [ __ ] pricks
[ __ ] and she just went off the
owner didn't know what to do because he
thought rita wasn't gonna curse he was
sitting down eating dinner the food went
flying out of his mouth he ran up there
took the mic from rita rita refused to
get off stage and he pushed her oh
all right so now we got drama
i'm gonna call the police you call
whoever you i'm gonna call them and
she's like i don't need the police i
have a gun she got well done
what was that
dog you have no [ __ ] idea
you have no [ __ ] idea
she had a gun and everything rita rita
used to get beat up she was four foot
[ __ ] nines he was a leprechaun her
head was
huge was the [ __ ] head
size eight oh my god new era her head
was [ __ ] bigger than mine lee your
head is small mine in your head no way
but she was a four foot two that's what
[ __ ] makes it
even the weirder that that's what she
was a little body with heels on
so
what are we talking about okay
so the guy throws her out of the club
and she's like joey whoever you guys got
to stick up for me we're like dog what
do you want us to do you can't curse
but you guys [ __ ] curse like well
yeah we got thrown out didn't we we
don't have no money
so now we go back to our house on the
way in the car wherever i'm with is
tormenting reader
rita's like i know my [ __ ] rights
i know my rights and there's a
transgender i'm a [ __ ] disability and
she's yelling in the car and she's dog
listen guys this woman would drink and
drive at the same time like i'm not
talking about drink and drive like you
drink at a bar and she would drink and
drive and not a drink mixed drink but
the bottle at the light
she was out there guys it was a
different [ __ ] type of person i'd be
sitting the car going when is this car
going to [ __ ] crash
so we get back to the house
i'm doing a couple lines and she's she
says what am i going to do with my life
when i get thrown out of comedy clubs
and i'm [ __ ] pushing her now now i'm
starting to have a good time
and i say that she goes you know what
i'm going to do i'm going to write a
letter to the president i go wing him
around to the president for call them up
at least i had this [ __ ] gets up at two
in the morning and calls the white house
right in front of me i'm [ __ ] howling
and they hang up on and she calls back
and then they [ __ ] call her back and
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] you i'm a disabled i want to talk
to the [ __ ] president i'm a stand-up
comedian they would not give me my
rights tonight the club is located it
was hilarious i'm there feeding the
[ __ ] you know call back call the
governor i don't care what time it is
poor rita oh so she used to dance at a
gay bar
they used to hire her like on tuesday
nights and she'd get on the podium and
dance but she kept falling because she
lose her balance between the alcohol and
the equilibrium from a big head this is
what people don't think
people think this is a joke when i say
it on stage ain't no [ __ ] joke her
head was so big that when she drank the
equilibrium because carol kept in touch
with her over those years
so one day carol called me she goes hey
you know rita i was dead
i know what happened she goes she lost
her balance at one of those clubs landed
on her head oh really got into a coma
and that's how she died oh
r.i.p rita oh i just want to tell you
[ __ ] the story the legend of
the seattle transgender that we both got
to her and taylor used to go at it they
would argue yeah oh tana would [ __ ] with
her [ __ ] you rita let me pull the wig
because everybody knew she had a wig it
was the ugliest [ __ ] thing in the
world well i thought it was real
guys that's the comedy scene at that
stage rudy sarzo came on here one day
and he goes you know
it's amazing
how music is on the borderline of mental
health
and i'm like what do you think stand-up
comedy is
you know 10 years ago the open mic at
the comedy store half of those people
boom chukkalaka you know yeah boom
chocolaty has friends you know he just
doesn't want to bring him no more
they'd show up down there in tuxedos and
[ __ ] homeless people
and stink up the place and do comedy and
not drink you think i'm kidding you you
know you don't remember those open mics
and see how like kid that used to go up
there and say this is my impersonation
of a cow
this is my impersonation of a fly
this is my impersonation of a [ __ ]
soldier that's what he would do for five
minutes wouldn't get a laugh
walk off stage pay his tab and leave
that was his therapy
half that [ __ ] is when you get on the
lower level of stand-up comedy and you
go to an open mic half of that room
could snap like a [ __ ] isis
soldier at any minute you just don't
know that
and they disappear amongst time they
don't grow because people know that
they're [ __ ] crazy when they do
something crazy at their first hosting
gig
at their first hosting gig they snap
they disappear after their first hosting
gig
those crazy [ __ ]
yeah there is a there's a bun it does
attract that kind of we knew the one kid
jeff masterson if you didn't think jeff
masterson was gonna [ __ ] do something
crazy
listen i'm no psychiatrist and i'm not a
[ __ ] no champion uh person
but even i knew jeff masterson jeff
masterson said something creepy to me
during the contest or something that i
had to look at him and go this guy is
[ __ ] out of his bird right
you know
he tried to push buttons sometimes too
yeah he was very uh small
one of those guys that's small and tiny
oh yeah yeah but he had a yeah he had a
a weird sense of humor he had that that
smile and he would say things to uh
antagonize you but you couldn't punch
him in the head because what were you
gonna get with it
but i also knew
that if i punched him in the head he was
gonna hit me with a chair eventually one
day
you know what i'm saying like that's
right there when i know that i just
leave those guys alone because we'll be
hitting each other with chairs for the
next 200 [ __ ] years he goes to the
hospital i go to the hospital he goes to
the hospital that i could tell he was
tiny and i could tell if he'd been into
you and he did fight somebody one night
i got attacked by al fox i was there i
had that on video somewhere no you don't
i do
what was out fox
tell these it was in the ba it was al
fox's uh had a motorcycle accident but
what was he at this point paraplegic
partially he walked he had a limp he had
a limp and a talk weird yeah joey [ __ ]
you yo
sorry
it's on i have it somewhere and you're
like like pushing his buttons he's
flipping he's like snarling at you it's
in the back he was foaming from the
mouth yeah it was going back yeah yeah i
have it on his videos how did you get
him so i don't know what happened he
came back and i took his chair
there's not that funny brody and he took
his [ __ ] shirt off and he wanted to
fight me he was shaking i'll kick your
[ __ ] air he was foaming from the
mouth
and i got up and i'm like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] why are you insulting me i
didn't know it was your chair
yeah he came it was over a chair he was
like something stupid
like a [ __ ] chair you know open mic
mondays where do you sit in the [ __ ]
back
anyway just to tell you some seattle
stories you [ __ ] brody stevens
you look great
thanks joey thank you for coming on the
show you got any upcoming shows coming
uh well i'm in town here i'm at the
comedy store in l.a i'm at the uh improv
here in la i'll be in um
gonna be out in dc and arizona but
that's not until october but i'm usually
here in los angeles at periscope prince
of periscope brodie is my friend
shows are always popping up southern
california i did irvine
i still do audience warm-up here and
there i'm having fun just gotta stay
healthy find out the next gig keep
podcasting this uh
this is all part of it
you're beautiful baby you're gonna give
me those league i'm gonna stare them
house i thought it was pretty good no
it's a good cast no no you're a bad
[ __ ] you know that's why i love
you i just gotta give you that you gotta
go get a sandwich and we'll get you out
of here all right
have you ever been to a local wildlife
have you ever been to a wine aisle at
your local store just staring at the
massive selection of wine with no idea
which bottle to choose
most of us go with the bottle that has
the best looking label and hope it's
going to be good well the days of
playing russian roulette with your wine
selections are over club w is here to
save you club w is a revolutionary new
wine club that takes the guesswork out
of choosing your wine they have a simple
six question palette quiz that will
match you with delicious high quality
wine you're guaranteed to love the best
part is club w will be shipped right to
your door no more going to the store
being lost in a while now your friend
calls you you don't know what the hell
you're doing you don't even know why the
hell you're there half the time try
living my life you understand me so do
me a favor all right right now club w is
offering listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to club w dot com
joey and it gets even better i know you
all have you all hate paying for
shipping so club w will actually pay for
your shipping on orders or four bottles
or more so take something off your to-do
list just go to club w dot com slash
joey to get 20 off your first order
right now that's club w dot com slash
joey listen this is the future wine you
want to sit in a
grocery store or a liquor store it's not
going to work out for you no more these
guys got terrific wine and like we said
before it gets delivered to your house
nobody knows nothing all right so again
go to clubw.com joey and get 20
off your first order right now all right
as usual on it the best
from the alpha brain to the hem force
protein to the shroom tech
i can't even talk about the wonders it's
done for me i love that little hem force
chocolate uh shake but do yourself a
favor the protein hemp force delicious
do yourself a favor go to honda.com
right now and take a look at the webpage
read about it
on the supplement side i'll get you ten
percent off and that's what i'm trying
to say to you whether you start with
alpha brand which you have 100 money
back guarantee or you want to try the
shroom tag or the shroom tank sport
let's try that route just to get it
started maybe you want more endurance in
jiu jitsu do me a favor go to hunter.com
church
and get 10 off your next order delivered
right to your [ __ ] house you
understand me
i'm going to be in
the funny bone friday and saturday
nebraska omaha nebraska and next two
weeks from now the 24th i'll be in
[ __ ] philadelphia jack at helium so
get your [ __ ] together i want to thank
club w i want to thank blue apron
delivering food right to your door and i
want to thank anit i want to thank brody
for coming on and my main man lisa
and uh becky my little angel over there
barefoot driving brody crazy he's
looking at your toes thinking how he's
going to bite into that [ __ ] i
have a foot fetish
that's right all right stay black i love
you [ __ ]
how long was that
an hour and a half
who's counting feels good
hey
so
so
just
so
so
so
you